what I want to do in this video is
review the revenue and cost graphs for a
monopoly for a monopoly so let's up here
let's draw the demand curve for the
monopoly and we're just going to speak
in general terms here for whatever our
products that we're the only person that
can produce it is let's say the demand
curve looks like this and I'm just going
to draw it as a line so we have a linear
we have a linear demand curve and this
axis right over here is dollars per unit
on the demand curve you could view that
as price and this horizontal axis is
quantity now over here what I want to do
is I'm still going to have quantity in
the horizontal axis but in the vertical
axis I'm going to have dollars not
dollars per unit so I can use this to
measure total revenue so if I don't
produce if I don't produce anything
right over here if my quantity is 0 how
much total revenue I'm going to get
regardless of what the price is well I'm
not going to get any total revenue my
total revenue measured in dollars is
going to be 0 if my quantity is out here
whatever this might be I'm selling a lot
but I'm selling it for free I'm giving
I'm giving the product away so once
again I have no total revenue so over
there
I have no total revenue and if we start
over here each incremental unit I'm
selling more and more or each
incremental unit right over here I'm
getting more and more and more and more
total revenue until some maximum point
and then I get less and less and less
total revenue and we saw that in
previous video so the total revenue
graph was going to look something like
that so that is total total revenue
often abbreviated as TR now from the
total revenue we can think about we can
look at this graph and we say look if we
increase the quantity a very small unit
how much are we increasing our total
revenue and so when we do that we're
essentially calculating marginal revenue
marginal revenue tells us how much does
our total revenue increase for a very
small change in quantity and it's
essentially the slope of this line so
the slope of the line there is very
steep and we saw in the previous video
that slope is right over here it's at
the same vertical intercept as our
demand curve and then it gets a little
less steep little less steep let me draw
more tangent a little less deep a little
less deep even less deep and then it the
slope actually becomes zero right here
and then it starts going and then it
starts going negative so right over here
if I wanted to plot the marginal revenue
which is the slope of the tangent line
here it starts off very steeply positive
and then it gets less positive less
positive less positive it hits zero
right around here right around here so
the marginal revenue curve looks like
that and then it actually keeps going
negative and this the way I drew it this
should be the zero point and then it
gets less steep and less deep just like
that and we've seen already we've proven
to ourselves that this marginal revenue
curve has twice the slope of the demand
curve this is the marginal revenue curve
and actually I left off an e and curve
for demand curve so that describes kind
of our revenue possibilities now let's
think about our cost possibilities so
down here let me draw a total cost curve
so our total costs so at first we don't
have much variable cost but we have some
fixed costs and then as we produce more
and more and more our variable costs
increase and so our total costs might
look something like that so that is
total total costs and just from this
graph down here we can actually start to
visualize what our economic profit is
and whenever we're talking about profit
in economic class 99% of the time we're
talking about economic profit we're
taking into account all of the
opportunity costs not just the explicit
ones where we're paying money but even
the implicit ones kind of the lost
opportunities that do to whatever we're
doing here in this business and to
visualize the economic profit so right
at this point so back here our total
costs are more than our total revenue so
this is an economic loss
this is break-even now we're starting to
make economic profit the economic profit
is just the difference between the total
revenue at top and the total costs on
the bottom if you subtract total cost
from total revenue you have your
economic profit and I should be clear
this is this is total economic costs
total economic cost opportunity just to
make sure that we realize we're done
what economic profit remember you could
have economic profit breakeven
you could have a normal profit but you
could still make an accounting profit so
if you're if you say you have zero
economic profit it does not mean that
you're not making any money it just
means that you're not making any money
above and beyond your opportunity costs
but anyway let's visualize so if we make
even more quantity the difference
between these two gets even bigger so
we're making even more economic profit
even more economic profit even more
economic profit and then right around
here it seems like it starts to shrink
again and we can think about it this way
while we're in this zone they're getting
further and further apart right over
here they're getting further and further
apart as long as the slope of the
magenta line as long as the slope of our
total revenue curve is larger than the
slope of our total cost curve the slope
the slope of the total revenue curve is
our marginal revenue the slope of our
total cost curve is marginal cost and we
can draw that so marginal cost will look
something like this marginal costs will
look something like we've got a little
bit different it would look something
like that and you could see here as long
as marginal revenue is larger than
marginal cost this is marginal cost that
means that the slope of the total
revenue is larger than the slope of the
total cost so they're going to get
further and further and further apart
but right when they're equal and then
beyond the point that they're equal
they're going to start getting closer
and closer together so at this point
right over here at this point right over
here the way I drew it so this point
right over here this should be the same
point right over here this is actually
your maximum economic profit and you can
visualize it by the height right over
here and we've thought about it this way
to looking at this chart you say look
that first unit my incremental revenue
on that first unit that's marginal
revenue is much higher and you know that
that first drop of whatever I'm
producing is much higher than the cost
for that unit so I I'm making economic
profit so I'm definitely going to
produce that I'm going to produce
another one still a marginal revenue
higher than marginal cost going to keep
producing until marginal revenue is
equal to marginal cost and at that point
I'm not going to produce any more
because if I produce any more my cost on
those incremental units are going to be
higher than my revenue on those
incremental units and though I'm going
to get an economic
loss on those units and I'm trying to
maximize economic profit and if we want
to visualize our economic profit up here
we have to graph our average total costs
so let's think of it this way you're
really taking your total costs you're
dividing it by quantity so when you have
a low quantity you have a lot of fixed
costs and and your fixed costs don't
change but you have very low quantity
you take a reasonably sized number
divided by a very small number you get a
very large number and let me do this in
green so I'm going to plot our average
total cost it's going to start up there
as long as our average total costs are
higher than our marginal costs then our
average total costs are going to come
down down down so they're going to come
down and down and down and then right
and then they're going to hit an equal
point and then right at that equal point
that means that my marginal cost is for
that extra that extra quantity of unit
the costs added are the same as my
average total cost and so the average
total costs aren't going to go down any
more and then as soon as the marginal
costs are higher than my average total
cost then each incremental unit is going
to add to my my average total cost is
going to start going up it starts going
to start averaging up so it's going to
look something like you'd see if I can
draw it a little bit differently so let
me let me draw it so really the marginal
cost and the average total cost should
intersect at the minimum of the average
total cost curve and I'll explain it
again in a second so our average total
cost code should look something let me
draw it a little bit better than that so
it could look something like something
like that right over here and just to
review what I said so this is the
average total cost as long as marginal
costs as long as the cost for each
incremental unit is lower than your
average total cost then producing an
extra unit since its costs are lower
than the average it's going to bring the
average down it's going to keep bringing
the average down until the marginal cost
is the same as the average total cost
now every incremental unit is higher
than the previous average so it's going
to start averaging everything up in
average total cost is going to go up
again so this should be the minimum
point of the average total cost curve
now with that out of the way we can
visualize the economic profit and
graph up here if this is the quantity
that we're producing this is our optimal
quantity then we say well what is the
price we're going to get in the market
we go to the demand curve so we go to
the demand curve that is the price that
we are going to get for it and then what
is our cost per unit you can view prices
revenue per unit
well our cost per unit is the average
total cost curve that's there so this
distance this yellow length right here
this is essentially my economic profit
per unit right it's my revenue per unit
minus my average total cost per unit and
if I want to get total economic profit I
multiply my economic profit per unit
times total number of units so this is
the total number of units so if I
multiply this base times this height I
get the area the area for this rectangle
right there and that is my total
economic profit total economic profit
economic profit for in the case of this
monopoly if we didn't have a monopoly
then we wouldn't have this downward
sloping marginal revenue curve and we
would actually if we were perfect if it
was if we were dealing with perfect
competition we would have to be price
takers in reactor we would actually have
a horizontal marginal revenue curve